[Musique]
la dépigmentation moi je l'appelle un
peu comme le viol des peaux noires fait
voter cinq thèmes un peu abusif
mais c'est l'ensemble des procédés
visant à obtenir un éclaircissement de
la peau aujourd'hui depuis les années
post coloniale de l'afrique
subsaharienne
on est phénomène depuis le sénégal à
partir de saint louis la colonisation a
commencé et dans toute l'afrique
subsaharienne
juste pour le congo il ya certes un pays
qui résiste à à à ce phénomène comme le
rwanda
j'ai toujours envie de citer ce pays
parce que ça montre qu'on peut penser
autrement voit les choses autrement
et cette idée celle est toujours je te
vois tu je n'étais pas un étudiant
travailleur j'ai passé participants dix
ans en faculté de médecine à lui merci
d'abomey calavi c'est pas facile
déjà frappés d'échouer parce qu'il faut
avoir à mettre chaque fois que je
reprenais la neige est obsédée par mon
père qui était mon maître
je suis deuxième génération de
dermatologues béninois jeudi m ah bon
cette année encore mais l'échec
il m'a dit c'est très bien on fit
qui prendra plus de temps mais tu
comprendras que la médecine est donc en
2014-2015 je faisais mes études à dakar
un hub et nietzsche et radios à
l'hôpital aristide le dantec
nous avons pu voir les premiers cas de
cancers cutanés
les premiers cas de karting pitt année
c'est pas des quartiers nos mains liées
par exemple à le ministre les carcinomes
qui sont liés à l'utilisation chronique
est prolongée de produits dépigmentants
et comme jeudi photo d'avant m j'ai
appelé mon père gelé des m'écoute vous
avez travaillé des années soixante dix
jusqu'aujourd'hui 2010 2015
n'avez-vous pas travailler plus les gens
arrêtent de se diviser ses produits
dépigmentants sur la peau m'a regardée
et puis m'a répondu en france je pars
parce qu'ils le font un peu un peu fort
quand il s'exprime un peu et directement
il m'a dit j'étais papier études du soir
un idiot et donc j'ai compris au début
je me sens un peu un peu mal mais à
présent réfléchissent aujourd'hui qu'il
n'est plus là je lui rends l'image
je me rend compte qu'aujourd'hui tout le
monde aujourd'hui elle apparaîtra de la
raisonner dans nos têtes comme il a
résonné dans la nièvre à midi
aujourd'hui nous les jeunes nous avons
aujourd'hui des problèmes des solutions
qui lui doivent venir que de nous parce
que les gens ont déjà fait un travail à
nous de réfléchir de nous adapter au
temps
pourquoi aujourd'hui ce set
dépigmentation s'observe dans no 6 et de
nos contrées en rentrant j'ai fait en
france bon vous n'allez pas voir des
pôles et d'énigmes automobile pharmacie
mais ici vous allez voir c'est vrai
qu'avant le marché il y en a dans les
multi cosmétiques il y en a dans les
pharmacies et lorsque vous c'est de voir
traçabilité donc ne s'est produit
cosmétique dans les pharmacies et vous
allez retrouver le producteur je me suis
fait le produit vous dites mais pourquoi
vous mettez y aux corticoïdes vous dit
bon écoute on a eu des idéaux qu'ils
nomment vous savez les femmes paient
toujours
finir plus belles devenir une l'air et
donc ça pose un problème réel
est ce que vous sentez bien dans votre
peau
c'est la pression à ce que le kop
problème c'est qu'il ya dans le mental
de l'individu du [ __ ] que je suis et
d'une ère que vous êtes donc des petites
tares en fait d'esclaves astrologie qui
pensent qu'on peut être plus beau en
étant moins foncée le ce problème me
traverse l'afrique est de plus en plus
vous avez des game en cosmétique je vais
l'appeler comme ça de grève et qui
sablent étudier non c'est pas assez près
sérieux ils sont étudiés correctement la
pensée du consommateur
si vous ne pouvez pas mettre dans votre
plat n'importe quoi ils m'ont dit c'est
la même façon que vous ne pouvez pas
mettre sur votre peau n'importe quel
produit parce que en étudiant sur des
pentes dans ces produits
si vous faites attention vous avez de
l'hydroquinone d'hydroquinone à des
présentatrices super gars y pensant que
vous avez des corticoïdes
vous avez des scènes de mercure et en
bas on achète ses produits à élever et
ancien bad jeunes après jusqu'à voir les
problèmes et nous aujourd'hui nous
allons plus attendre dans les hôpitaux
on au cabinet des malades qui vont venir
nous exposer donc les feuilletons donc
de cette de ce fléau qui aujourd'hui et
nous mène de santé publique
et c'est pour cela que dans la décision
de passer donc avec notre ne vont pas
d'argent pour faire du grand panneau
d'affichage mais ne passait par
l'oralité et bien qu'ils vont nous a
baigné dans mon envie de mon avenir
ils ont dix ans à venir les rumeurs ça
va d'un très bien avec le tmx que c'est
une pâte une information compact à
l'oralité et qui avait terminé la
technologie nous permet d'atteindre
justement nous ne pouvons pas dire nous
allons combattre la dépigmentation
nous allons ni des comptes à des
paiements pass sont partout des gens ont
déjà essayé les personnages sénégal et
dans plusieurs pays de la sous région
mais nous pouvons apporter d'une
information crédible
donc nous fait de la discrimination
positive envers la peau noire et de
faire en sorte que les habitudes
changent et pour qu'une sortir de la
longue nuit de noce vérité du complexe
de la peau noire ou du complexe d'avoir
une peau moins foncée si vous êtes
africains si mauvais si vous vivez sous
le soleil tropical
c'est nous avait une peau 7 pouces et
wau et la première couche et ne tient à
rien c'est l'épiderme
vous allez vous l'avez c'est une je
fasse enlever ce seront surtout les
virus
vous avez ensuite deux couches
inférieures le dernier l'hypoderme ils
vont contenir donc alors d'élastine qui
nous permet de lassitude et de
l'élasticité de la peau
le collagène qui va permettre la
tonicité de la peau il avait une
substance qu'on appelle les mélanocytes
que les albinos sont malheureusement
avec une pro du pas la mélamine
cette médaille et ida qui va être là va
protéger votre peau des rayons
ultraviolets et donc aussi bien dans
votre routine que ce votre peau vous
avez sept mille ans qui est produite
avez votre a bien qu'ils aient produit
qui répétait à travers la haute vienne
et donc personne ne peut détruire 7 mai
la ligne de façon isolée sans toucher à
la bien sans toucher au collagène sont
couchés à l'élasticité de la peau
la communauté de la route donc
aujourd'hui le combat c'est vous faire
passer notre information parce que on a
bien essayé de techniques les
pharmaciens médecins les six couleurs
mais le grand métier c'est le bleu le
plus grand objectif c'est de sortir les
populations de l'ignorance psychologique
et des sorties de l'allant tenu de la
longue nuit noire que l'on traverse
j'aimerais finir par demander quelque
chose qui me motivait choque beaucoup
c'est quoi dépigmentant nouveau les
nourrissons nos enfants et c'est des
choses aux gens qui arrivent mais
aujourd'hui il faut parler de l'endroit
en des emplois
pourquoi launois n'arrive pas dire à sa
fiancée mais tu te montres ebel
j'aimerais bien te vois toujours comme
ça avec leurs dépôts c'est très rare pas
de pondre des hommes niveau femmes
belle vous est admirable vous êtes
magnifique et que vous êtes resté tel
que vous êtes mais après je me suis dit
mais c'est trop simple franck mois c'est
trop simple j'ai défini technique et
puis je veux voir une belle dame je lui
dis exclusivement madame excuse moi de
vous déranger de très belles
applaudissent et ben c'est parce que ça
parce que en général en afrique quand tu
dis ça une femme des femmes sont
tellement commercial qui sont déjà dans
des affaires pas très avancé non je
voudrais demander aux femmes de ne plus
voir nous écouter quand on l'a dit
franchement madame même si vous voyez
une épaule et qui vous dit que vous êtes
prêt belle pour le compliment et
j'aimerais finit par cette phrase de
martin luther king
ceux qui comptent plus chez un homme ce
n'est ni la couleur de sa peau ni la
texture de sa chevelure mais c'est la
qualité du sauna parquet de mons je
remercie
[Applaudissements]